[Musique]
gates teny
quel contact visuel intense et
interminable on va aller voir ailleurs
et qu'on était ensemble depuis neuf ans
je pensais qu'on pourrait tout surmonté
jusqu'au jour où je viens de décrocher
un poste à san francisco j'ai
l'impression qu'on doit vivre nos
propres vies comment y lost quitté quand
il est même pas dit pourquoi pas essayer
regarde toi tu es une bombe avec de
belles dents merci c'est gentil tube
elle tint pas besoin de ça je pense
vraiment et confiance entre une
impression poser pour une pub avant
après à côté de toi qui je dois tuer est
ce que ça va en gros je veux que vous
appeliez à vos boulots pour leur dire
que vous avez vos règles ou chez paquet
de mythos et que vous veniez chez moi tu
vois le début de ce genre de film au
scénar catastrophe juste avant qu'une
fille comme moi crève et genre au moment
où la fille comme toi se promène dans la
rue et dit oh mon dieu regarde comme le
ciel est trop jolie
bah là ça craint autant je pars dans une
semaine j'aurai trente ans les gens
mouraient probablement j'ai besoin d'une
dernière journée de folie avec mes
copines
[Musique]
au repos durant le musée sérieux ça me
donne carrément envie de nous des shows
là je peux pas quitter new york là
dessus
c'est la fin d'une ère tout est en train
de changer tu vis à vis à fond tu prends
des risques
super mignon était une petite amie car
tu es jolie petite étiquette était en
normatives dans un de placard
merci beaucoup
tu fais des choix osé genre avec ce mec
que tu détestes désolé je voulais te
faire une petite blague
ma chérie c'est impossible que ça se
finisse comme ça tu dois y croire et
garde espoir génie lui envoie palais ça
fait chier
allez tu peux le faire
je vous adore les filles
notre meilleur pote et là à boire du
champagne dans une bouteille de jus de
légumes et pouvoir la serrer fort et
fait repartir sa douleur ça fait une
sorte de mimosa ou jus league
c'est ingénieux je me sens mieux
maintenant vous en faites pas je ramasse